this is Startalk alex is coming to us
from earth and alex says hey I just
turned 30 hey happy birthday man how
feasible is it in my lifetime to see
people land on Europa now I suppose he's
singing amusing the average lifespan
because we don't know
Alex could be hit by a bus next week you
know that's not what with what I don't
think that's the life expectancy he's
planning for this question
okay you're right if you can hit my bus
next week you ain't never seen this
happening all right so so in the average
lifespan now I'd like to believe that
before Alex turns 100 okay there's the
positive outlook
yeah Alex see that we might be able to
send people to Europa that would just be
very cool that would happen only the day
we are like the solar system is our
backyard it that what I don't see that
as a destination itself I see that as
just one of the many things we're doing
in space right it's visiting Europe and
it'd be very cool I talked about going
to Europa all the time
yeah go ice fishing on Europa it's an
outer icy layer layer of ice and stress
from Jupiter's gravity heats Europa by
the way Europa and Jupiter outside of
the Goldilocks zone right so if you're
outside of it your water is evaporated
because you're too close you're frozen
because you're too far away right
Jupiter pumps energy into Europa because
of its gravity and has melted the ice
beneath the surface so we've got a it's
like an mmm mmm moon candy outside yes
it's all nice watery squishy inside so
you're out there and I want to go like I
said there's many times I want to go ice
fishing on Europa there's a movie called
the Europa report which is about the man
man's first mission to Europa and so and
they and they want to look for life
there so yeah I think that could happen
definitely in his lifetime well with all
those oceans underneath Europa how
likely is the
the possibility of life because well
water and life go together
yeah and in hand here on earth and I've
said this before there's life every
place on earth where there's water
liquid water even the Dead Sea correct
now why is there life in the Dead Sea
why is it called the Dead Sea cuz they
okay there no macroscopic fishes
swimming around but at the time they
named it the Dead Sea you know they
didn't have no microscope okay there you
go
said as there you have it right so
they're defining their world by what
their senses tell them when in fact what
science is all about is extending your
senses and creating new ways of
detection that your biological form
can't even approximate and then you
deduce the nature of the world gotcha
yeah sweet alright great question Alex
and hope you live to be a hundred buddy
okay good this is Startalk